True horror.
The airplane door, belching smoke, and burning
red light.
The dead talking in ancient, guttural Latin.
A monstrous angel made of rings, wings, and
eyes whipping barbed tentacles at screaming,
terrified priests.
You can scarcely imagine a more hellish place.
Bishop Franklin’s knees gave out under him
as soon as the man set foot back on solid
ground.
Nearing his 70th birthday, he’d never been
a particularly tough man, but after the day
he’d had, he doubted he’d ever be the
same again.
Almost being ripped into another dimension,
almost being at the center of a nuclear explosion,
seeing…
He threw up on the ground as the Foundation
personnel rushed over to him.
Never - never - again!
*
Just eight hours earlier, Bishop Franklin
had been getting on with his Friday preparations.
They had mass coming up this weekend, so he
was doing the rounds of the cathedral, putting
out new candles, and straightening pews.
He was nearly done, ready to get on with the
rest of his morning, when he saw the two suited
figures entering the cathedral.
He shuffled over to them, trying to explain
that they were closed, but quickly faltered
when he saw the grave looks on their faces.
Just 10 minutes later, he was in the back
of their car, still holding a spare candle,
with agents from the SCP Foundation sitting
on either side of him.
They handed him file after file, each most
redacted, explaining the basis of who they
were and where they were headed.
It was a lot for the old priest to wrap his
head around.
He’d always believed in a higher power and
a spiritual realm, but this sounded a whole
lot more serious than that.
Monsters, aliens, other dimensions, facilities,
portals?
He questioned the agents on it.
They just looked grimly from one to another
as the car wound its way to the private airstrip
in the middle of nowhere.
*
Bishop Franklin had always hated flying, but
he hated it a whole lot more as he approached
the airplane with no idea where he’d be
landing.
A small group of men was gathered on the runway
just by the foot of a Boeing passenger plane.
It seemed like a pretty substantial plane
for such a small group of them.
He was at least a little heartened to see
that none of them had brought luggage either.
In fact, most of them were just like him.
As Bishop Franklin approached the group, he
recognized various faces, other bishops, archbishops,
and senior priests.
With him there, they totaled seven.
The others all looked at him, not saying much.
Bishop Franklin tried his best to start asking
questions, but two things happened in quick
succession that closed his mouth very quickly.
Firstly, the luggage hold of the plane was
opened, and two enormous shapes were loaded
into it via forklift.
Each shape had unmistakable symbols on the
sheets covering them.
Nuclear danger.
Reeling from this revelation, Bishop Franklin
turned to the group to be face-to-face with
the Pope himself.
He immediately shut his mouth.
*
You may also be wondering what on earth was
going on at this airfield.
The truth is, Bishop Franklin, along with
six other priests of Abrahamic faiths, were
about to embark on the monthly flight of SCP-616.
Within this plane, as all of these men were
soon about to find out, exists an emergency
door.
Covered with Satanic iconography, this door,
when opened at ground level, operates just
like any emergency door, leading to the outside
of the plane.
Although any individuals who have passed through
the door in this ‘normal’ state report
feeling heightened anxiety during and after.
However, once a month, this door will be anything
but normal, opening a gate to… well, you’ll
soon see.
In order to mitigate the threat posed to humanity
through SCP-616-1 or The Gate, the plane must
be in the air at the time of its opening,
far above and away from any human settlements.
In order to keep this event contained, the
door must be kept open for the duration of
the portal’s existence until it has closed
of its own accord.
But holding this door open is not a simple
test of strength.
It’s a test of belief.
In order to protect all of humanity from unknown
horrors of a cataclysmic scale, seven priests
of Abrahamic faiths must be on board for this
monthly flight, praying for the door to remain
open.
The ability to keep the door open, it turns
out, is unrelated to physical prowess but
instead is based entirely on one’s own belief
that the door can be held open.
As such, religious figures praying to a higher
power are incredibly well suited to the task.
Once per year, the flight is blessed by the
Pope, and every time the plane takes off,
it must be holding two nuclear warheads in
its hull.
Both can be remotely detonated by the ground
team ,who are to be in constant radio communication
with the pilot.
Should the pilot fail to give them regular
updates on the status of SCP-616-1, the event
will be treated as an XK-Class End-of-the-World
scenario, and both nuclear devices will be
detonated without hesitation.
*
But Bishop Franklin only knew about half of
this information from his redacted set of
documents and had forgotten half of that on
his stressful car journey.
As he strapped himself into a window seat,
he was trembling like a leaf.
He desperately wanted to complain about being
put into this situation, but he wasn’t entirely
sure who he could complain to.
If he spoke to anyone external about what
he was about to witness, he had been told
by the Foundation agents that he would be
‘administered with a class-C amnestic’
whatever that meant.
He didn’t really want to find out.
Fortunately for him, the most familiar of
the faces from the group of priests sat next
to him in the aisle seat.
Bishop…
what was his name?
Sensing Bishop Franklin’s uncertainty, the
man reached a hand over and warmly reintroduced
himself.
Bishop Pete.
They’d met two years ago in Berlin.
Just that small action was almost enough to
settle Bishop Franklin’s nerves as the plane
started to barrel down the runway.
Almost.
The plane took off, causing the old man’s
stomach to drop.
Heart hammering, he looked around, spotting
the emergency door.
It was just up ahead of him, around the middle
of the fuselage.
It would have looked like a normal emergency
exit, but for the blood-red markings scrawled
across it.
A wave of dread washed over him.
It certainly looked evil, that was for sure.
Trying his best to help, Bishop Pete struck
up a conversation.
He explained it wasn’t his first time doing
this.
He’d been drafted in to help three months
ago.
It was scary, for sure, but everything was
totally fine.
The Foundation had planned everything to a
T. It would have helped Bishop Franklin’s
nerves, but it only made his mind jump to
the nuclear weapons he’d seen loaded into
where his suitcase would normally have gone.
The two of them lapsed into silence for a
while.
No one on the plane was really speaking.
He supposed he should have used this opportunity
to pray, but according to his briefing, he’d
be doing a lot of that very soon.
He hadn’t entirely understood what the Foundation
had meant by that.
He’d been told to pray to ‘keep the door
open’.
What had they meant by that?
A bang shattered the silence as the emergency
door slammed wide open.
In an instant, the plane went into a nosedive
as all the air rushed from inside.
The lights went out for several seconds, then
came back on in flashing, panicked spasms.
Bishop Franklin clung for dear life onto the
back of the chair in front of him as the roar
of air rushed around him.
It had gone dark outside, with shapeless clouds
swirling around him, shaking the plane.
Screaming voices filled the aircraft.
Not just the voices of the men on board but
women and children too.
Crying out in agony and terror through throats
that sounded like they’d been lashed with
razor wire.
Then he saw…
it.
SCP-616-1, the Gate, was wide open.
Smoke billowed out of it, crawling along the
floors of the cabin like an octopus creeping
its way along the ocean floor.
Red light seemed to spill out of it, but when
he tried to look through the gate itself,
it was like his brain wasn’t working anymore.
There were colors there, but they were ones
he didn’t recognize, maybe they weren’t
colors at all.
It was like his brain fixated on trying to
sort them into something that made sense,
something rational.
A hand grasped his arm, and he turned to see
Bishop Pete staring at him with wild eyes.
The plane was going down, they could both
feel it, and that emergency door was slowly
creeping shut.
They had been brought onto this plane for
one job only.
To pray like their lives depended on it.
Bishop Franklin screwed his eyes shut and
clasped his hands together.
He hadn’t prayed like that since he was
a little kid, but he figured now was the time
to use all the tricks in the book.
He begged and pleaded in a tiny voice for
God to keep that door open.
It felt so counterintuitive, so backwards,
to want to keep that kind of door open as
the air roared and screamed around him, but
a small voice inside him told him to persevere.
Have a little faith!
But suddenly, the Bishop noticed that the
man sitting alongside him had fallen silent.
Feeling like a naughty child at mass, he opened
one eye and peered sideways.
Bishop Pete was still in his seat but he’d
slumped over.
He wasn’t breathing.
His skin was cold to the touch, deathly cold.
Then all of a sudden, his head rocked backwards
and he started talking.
Not talking like a normal man, but talking
like a man possessed.
His dead eyes rolled around in his head aimlessly
as a guttural voice rasped out of his throat.
None of them were words that Bishop Franklin
recognized.
They sounded almost like Latin but far darker
and more ancient.
And the more the dead man spoke, the more
the emergency door closed.
The Bishop started praying again, much harder
this time, digging his fingernails into his
palms so hard he felt them drawing blood.
He needed to keep this door open.
He had to, and he could; he believed it entirely
in that moment.
The door banged back open, wider than ever,
despite the chanting of the dead body in the
seat next to him.
Nightmares swelled to the forefront of his
mind as the plane hurtled to the ground.
*
Only, the plane wasn’t hurtling to the ground.
In fact, it was flying at a perfectly steady
altitude of 10,972m with an airspeed speed
of about 780km/h.
In fact, aside from the death of Bishop Pete,
everything within the plane was going perfectly
to plan.
Deaths of priests were just an occupational
hazard of keeping this SCP contained.
The pilot at the front of the plane regarded
the whole situation playing out behind him
while feeding constant information back to
base.
Everything was going perfectly according to
plan.
Until the angel appeared.
*
Bishop Franklin wasn’t the first one to
see it.
That was the unfortunate lot of Archbishop
Michael, who was sitting closest to the emergency
door.
He first spied it while staring through into
the void, but his screams of terror, warning
those around him, were drowned out by all
of the other commotion.
It was only when the angel’s wings crept
their way through the edges of the door, and
the creature let itself into the cabin that
the others saw it.
But by this point, it was too late for Archbishop
Michael.
The angel was not like the angels we see in
pop culture, a tall blonde person with white
robes, fluffy wings, and a gentle face.
It was a shifting mass of eyes and tortured
wings, partially crawling along the ground,
partially floating under the weight of its
massive frame.
It had to squeeze itself through the door
to fit into the plane.
But as it did, it lashed out at the Archbishop
with a sinewy tendril and got to work, violently
killing him.
That was when Bishop Franklin saw it and began
to panic.
He wanted nothing more than to stop praying,
to let the emergency door slam shut, and keep
this creature away from them, but that little
voice inside his head told him that wouldn’t
work.
If that door was allowed to close before the
gate had, then it would cause the apocalypse.
He couldn’t have that blood on his hands.
So he prayed, sweat pouring down his face
as the angel forced its way through the gate
and into the cabin.
He prayed as it slumped across the aisles,
working its way along the line of men, slaughtering
them one by one.
He prayed as it saw him and rose to its full
height, unfurling great wings and readying
itself for the kill.
And he prayed as a wind more powerful than
any on earth blew through the cabin and pulled
the angel back through the gate.
The emergency door slammed shut, and in an
instant, the plane seemed to right itself.
No more turbulence, no more wind.
The lights flickered once more and then came
back on steady.
The seatbelt sign pinged off.
And the oxygen masks dropped down from the
ceiling, about 4 hours too late.
Bishop Franklin couldn’t believe the time
when he looked at his wristwatch.
He had been on this plane for weeks surely,
not just 4 hours.
That was absurd!
It all felt like a dream as the aircraft circled
around the airstrip, preparing for landing.
Everything in the plane seemed totally normal
to him now.
Except, of course, for the four dead bodies,
one of which was slumped towards him in the
aisle seat.
The plane landed, the Bishop staggered down
the stairs and threw up on the blacktop.
After a few awkward moments, the pilot sidled
over to him and muttered a quick thanks.
‘I was real close to calling it a failure
there and having them set off the nukes.
I don’t know what you prayed for, but you
did good today.’
Bishop Franklin didn’t feel like he did
good.
He felt like he’d had his whole life, his
whole worldview, turned upside down in the
space of an interstate flight.
He had been moments away from either being
vaporized by a nuclear bomb or from having
economy seats to the premiere of the destruction
of the world as we know it.
But just 31 days later, Bishop Franklin was
on that same flight again, praying his hardest
as the aircraft dropped into freefall.
If there was one thing that the Foundation
noticed about working with religious leaders,
it was that they had a real determination
to keep coming back to help keep the world
safe.
What the Foundation didn’t have the heart
to tell them was that all of the Satanic markings
on the door were actually fake.
They had been added by researchers in an attempt
to make SCP-616-1 carry more significance
for those in the aircraft.
Later testing revealed that it was not exclusive
to Abrahamic faiths, or any faith groups for
that matter, that they could keep the gate
open.
Anyone who believed they could do it was capable
of it.
Faith leaders, however, are still being utilized,
and the blessing is still being performed
by the Pope on a yearly basis.
It has been found that these external rituals,
while not necessarily directly impactful,
have strengthened the belief and resolve of
those inside the plane, yielding fewer casualties
and shorter durations.
Various experiments have been conducted to
see beyond the ‘event horizon’ of the
gate.
To see what’s on the other side.
Those in the plane have reported it as having
the name ‘Paradise’ despite never going
inside.
A remote-controlled rover was sent inside
the gate on one experiment, but the footage
was deemed far too dangerous as all those
who witnessed it died within two months.
Hopefully, you didn’t peer too closely into
the gate as you watched this video…
Now check out “The Plane That Never Was
SCP-787” and “SCP-2086 Man Eating Bus”
for more!